alors que l'économie est à l'arrêt qu'on
approche des 500 mille cas dans le monde
les géants des technologies les gars
femmes ont donné un peu plus de 200
millions de dollars pour soutenir la
guerre contre la copie de 19 c zéro
virieu 0 2% de leurs richesses
brigitte alepin fiscaliste bonsoir oui
concevoir
est-ce que c'est assez non il fait que
je sais c'est certain que ce n'est pas
suffisant pour 2 0 point 0 2% de la
richesse des gars femmes de leur
fondateur de leurs fondations
celle qui vaut pour une personne qui est
une richesse de sang mais dollars a
donné 20 dollars donc on sait que
lorsqu'on est milliardaire on peut
donner un peu plus donc
et évidemment on s'aperçoit si on prend
par exemple le code facebook pour
prendre un cas précis facebook a donné
20 millions dans les coffres de facebook
l'actif net de la société selon les plus
récents états financiers présentent des
actifs nets de cent mille millions de
dollars donc donné 20 millions de
dollars en totalité c'est bien peu et le
fondateur lui-même à ce jour selon des
informations publiques évidemment
n'aurait rien donné et sa fondation non
plus bon vous vous avez justement
d'abord vous analysez toujours les
enjeux de fines entre pie de dons et les
gars femmes lydon dégâts femmes leur
fondateur leurs fondations de charité
pour voir comment ils ont contribué
depuis le début de cette crise à la
lutte contre la copie de 19
comment vous avez structurer organiser
cette analyse en fait ce qu'on ce qu'on
a fait c'est que puisque les gars femmes
sont réputées pour payer peu ou pas
d'impôts et d'ailleurs on leur a dédié
la une partie de la réforme fiscale
mondiale
c'est important pour nous d'aller voir
si ces entreprises là qui sont réputés
de ne pas payer leur juste part d'impôts
est ce qu'elles sont au rendez-vous
lorsque les sociétés sont en crise pour
faire des contributions volontaires
donc on analyser pour chacune des
sociétés dégâts femmes c'est quoi qui
ont donné en tout cas selon sur la place
publique les informations qui sont à
notre disposition ce que leurs
fondateurs ordonnée est ce que leur
fondation en donner et on s'aperçut et
on veut voir le résultat parce qu'on a
préparé un tableau à partir des données
justement que vous nous avez fait
parvenir google apple facebook amazon
microsoft google avec son fondateur
larry page 51 millions de dollars
américains c représente 0,02 % de la
part de la richesse la wii 2 de
l'entreprise et du fondateur impose ses
15 millions
mark zuckerberg et facebook c'est 20
millions 0 0 1% amazon jeff bezos h 34
millions et microsoft bill gates 125
millions c'est 0.05 pour ça oui
exactement donc ayez qui lieu de se
questionner si ces entreprises là ne
paient peu ou pas d'impôts ne paient pas
leur juste part d'impôts et au lieu de 2
c'est important d'aller vérifier c'est
quoi leur contribution qu'elles font en
temps crise qu'on s'aperçoit que
évidemment 0 point 0 2% ou dans le cas
de mark zuckerberg et facebook 0 point 0
1% de la richesse c'est évidemment une
capacité de contribuer de façon beaucoup
plus importante et on s'aperçoive j'ai
aussi ex tensionnelle analyse pour voir
si canada oui pour voir si au canada nos
milliardaires no 42 milliardaire
canadien n'était pas un peu plus
généreux est malheureux et
malheureusement on est on est obligé de
constater que nos médias des canadiens
ne sont pas plus généreux si on prend
les les top 12 de nos milliardaire
canadien on
il contribue seulement 5 dans le fond on
fait une certaine contribution à la
crise du covin 19 et par exemple sont
prend alain bouchard et couche-tard
[Musique]
ce qui ne contribue ce sont des cafés
gratuits aux employés de la santé sont
prend du plomb dans l'ailé les mesures
qui contribuent ce c'est la possibilité
de faire une séance de méditation en
ligne gratuite avec lui les mines si on
prend par exemple il ya une weston
mettons de weston augmentation du
salaire des employés
oui donc pour des employés de l'aube là
mais si west hyundai propose une
augmentation de 15 % des employés des
magasins loblaw les potes de dons
directs à l'aube et 19 sont vos goûts
dans la lutte à la coved non pas sur le
top 12 en cov et un ce que ça nous dit
en temps de crise
votre constat la filtre fine entropie et
les philanthropes joue t'il vraiment le
rôle en temps de crise ce qu'on voit en
tout cas présentement on s'aperçoit que
non ils ne jouent pas leur rôle
donc ça nous porte nous les spécialistes
en partie puisque ac qui travaillons
beaucoup pour un forum fiscal mondial et
par exemple nous les fondatrices aussi
de taxes quoi ça nous ça nous confirme
que c'est plus important que jamais de
s'assurer qu'on va aller de l'avant avec
cette réforme fiscale mondiale a pour
s'assurer que tous les contribuables
paient l'ancien stoppeur d'impôts et
spécialement les mieux nantis qui ont
réussi durant les 20 dernières années a
échappé au régime au régime fiscal parce
que lorsque ça vient tant de ce qui est
sur eux pour faire des contributions
volontaires ils ne sont pas en tout cas
jusqu'à présent au rendez vous donc
c'est absolument important est d'autant
plus présentement ça va être encore plus
important de s'assurer que c'est nos
régimes d'imposition vont aller chercher
la juste part parce que les citoyens les
populations vont demander nature en
dépôt chez moi une sauce this fiscal
parce qu'elle y sommes il valoir prix à
payer à cette crise là merci beaucoup de
cette démonstration brigitte alepin ce
soit
merci beaucoup merci